jo Leute was geht und herzlich
willkommen aus Wien im leicht
verregneten dieseligen Wien hier ist
niemand unterwegs liegt daran wir haben
gerade knapp kurz vor 7 Uhr an einem
Dienstag ich bin gerade auf jeden Fall
unterwegs von London mit dem Zug bis
nach Istanbul da klingt ein bisschen
bescheid ich weiß aber so ist das normal
hier einen Ticket gekauft und zwar
fahren wir jetzt gleich von Wien nach
Budapest weiter hat auch nur 40 € kostet
das glaube ich das günstigste Ticket der
Reise wir fahren auch nur 3 Stunden aber
ich wusste gar nicht dass das so schnell
geht von Wien nach Budapest auf jeden
Fall wenn ich dann gleich da bin werde
ich erstmal chillen weil ich bin
wirklich mies fertig oh ich könnte auch
einfach da ins Motel One gehen hinter
mir ich bin jetzt seit fast 24 Stunden
schon unterwegs und habe ungefähr 1600
km mit dem Zug geschafft also ich habe
wirklich einfach nur drauf gehämmert und
habe nirgendwo ist auch schade so ich
könnte mir auch mal Wien anschauen oder
halt irgendwie war ich schon Zürich
Paris London hätte ich mir alles
anschauen können aber ich dachte kommen
wir hasseln einfach durch und gucken mal
wie schnell man ankommt ja jetzt geht's
wieder in Bahnhof weil mein Zug kommt in
30 Minuten
ich würde mir gerne noch ein Käffchen
holen Leute weiter geht's bis gleich zum
Zug ist da ich glaube das ist einfach so
ein Regionalzug wahrscheinlich von
Österreich oder Railjet Business ich
dachte eigentlich das ist ein
ungarischer Zug aber ist mir auch egal
Hauptsache ich komme dahin kommt noch
ein Käffchen hier dabei Restaurant okay
nee das kann ja dann doch keinen
Regionalzug sein oder gibt es in
Österreich Restaurants auf den
regionalflügen könnt ihr das mal
kommentieren hallo ich möchte mitfahren
so hier maskenpflicht einer
[Musik]
so Leute wir sind jetzt hier gerade über
die Grenze gefahren ich weiß GPS sind ab
und sind jetzt hier in hey die Serien
das sieht alles so trist aus nee das
kann man mit Freunden vor acht Jahren
hier im Park Urlaub und ich glaube sogar
da fahren wir gleich lang ich bin mal
gespannt es war auf jeden Fall am
Balaton und ja wann wilder Urlaub mit
dem Zug Verfahren und ich weiß auch da
sind wir irgendwo im Nirgendwo gelandet
und das sah aus wie mitten in Afrika das
ist voll krass hier also Ungarn ist ja
an sich ein cooles Land aber in manchen
schnell auch ein bisschen aber sonst
habe ich noch nie irgendwas von Ungarn
gesehen und ich fand es wirklich
spannend da so lang zu fahren weil man
muss halt sagen das sieht die Welt an
vielen Stellen ich meine das gar nicht
böse aber irgendwie so ein bisschen
triste aus als bei uns und auch die
Bahnhöfe sahen na ja eigentlich noch
schlimmer aus als der Hauptbahnhof von
Hagen wie gesagt Leute ich meins
überhaupt nicht böse das ist mir nur
halt aufgefallen ich weiß dass Budapest
super schön ist sonst war die Landschaft
aber eigentlich wie in Deutschland ist
ja auch nicht anders zu erwarten und
nach einiger Zeit bin ich dann so in den
Vororten von Budapest angekommen
überhaupt noch ein bisschen für euch
gefilmt keine Ahnung kann man hier sehen
ich glaube so ein paar Hochhäuser waren
da auf jeden Fall aber ich bin mal
gespannt was mich dann am Ende in
Rumänien erwartet weil das wird
natürlich auch super interessant und ich
freue mich schon sehr darauf hier kann
man dann noch sehen wie ich in Budapest
ankomme musste ich aussteigen und habe
dann erstmal so einen Mann gesehen der
von so einer Treppe gefallen ist aber
vielleicht ein ganz kurzer Ausschnitt so
Leute was geht ich bin angekommen in
Budapest ah Taube endlich ey und jetzt
heißt es wir haben zwar morgens aber
schauen einfach dass ich mir hier
irgendwo ein Hotel Buche wo ich dann
jetzt erstmal einchecken kann mich ein
bisschen ausruhen kann und dann mal
gucken kann wie es weitergeht oh
shutter
gefallen aber ich weiß auch nicht was
ich mir jetzt
erstmal kurz Erste Hilfe geleistet erst
hat man von der Stufe gefallen aber der
hat halt einfach zu viel getrunken da
kann man dann auch nicht mal so viel
machen ich brauche jetzt ein Hotel ach
so die weiteren Pläne sind übrigens noch
Nachtzug bis nach Bukarest ich glaube
der fährt 16 Stunden und von da aus dann
noch bis nach Istanbul noch mal 18
Stunden irgendwie so ich habe noch keine
Ahnung wie es mache aber ja Budapest
gucke ich mir vielleicht dann mal an
sieht hier jetzt noch nicht so nice aus
aber ich weiß dass Budapest eigentlich
ganz schön ist Taxi und ich sag dem
Taxifahrer can you bring me to good
hotel please so let's go and your
ansonsten Leute beende ich den Block
hier wir sehen uns dann nächsten Part
wieder wenn es heißt Nachtzug nach
Bukarest und diesmal auf jeden Fall
privates Abteil sonst bin ich definitiv
raus Leute was geht ich melde mich von
zu Hause aus ich wollte noch kurz ein
zwei Worte loswerden zu der Wien
Budapest Reise erstmal sorry ich weiß
das war jetzt kein langes Video einfach
weil die Reise dahin auch nicht lang war
und ich habe überlegt ob ich es wirklich
einfach ins nächste Video mit reinpacken
nur dann kann man es einfach nicht so
gut Staffeln weil ich wirklich in jedem
Video eigentlich einen Zug haben möchte
und im nächsten Video soll es dann
einfach nur um den nächsten Nacht zu
gehen der eigentlich ganz cool war
trotzdem habe ich mir überlegt dass bei
diesem Railjet eine Bewertung jetzt
eigentlich gar keinen Sinn macht also
das war alles in Ordnung soweit aber ich
will jetzt nicht Service und Essen und
so bewerten einfach weil das kein Zug
war wo das Sinn macht war halt nur eine
Strecke die ich machen musste um
weiterzukommen ich konnte heute nicht
danach zu komplett durch einfach
Budapest buchen ich war danach wirklich
fast 30 Stunden durch den Zug fahren
endlich mal eine Hotel und habe da
gechillt was cool war in der nächsten
Folge ein Kumpel von mir kam dann dazu
und wir waren zu zweit das kam mir auch
echt recht weil ja zu zweit Reis ist
einfach entspannter und es passiert auf
jeden Fall noch jede Menge ich hoffe ihr
habt Bock drauf deswegen abonniert super
gerne den Kanal ja Leute vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen und haut rein ciao